Transcriber: Gözde Alpçetin
Gözden geçirme: Ozay Ozaydin
Herkese merhaba.
Ben Hamza.
Sosyal medyada içerik üreticisiyim.
YouTuber olarak da tanınıyorum.
Şimdi, bugünkü konumuz olan büyük adım
kişiden kişiye değişen bir şey
olduğunu düşünüyorum.
Akademik hayatta büyük adım,
aşk hayatında büyük adım,
aile hayatında büyük adım gibi gibi
birçok konuda büyük adımlar atabilirsiniz.
Bugün benim size
bahsetmek istediğim büyük adım
bizzat kendi hayatımdan da
birden fazla kez attım
ve onlardan da
birkaç tane örnek vereceğim.
Konfordan konforsuzluğa, bilinmezliğe
doğru atılan adımlar hakkında.
Tekrardan söylüyorum, benim adım Hamza.
Sosyal medyada içerik üreticisiyim
ve oradaysa
Japon Hamza olarak tanınıyorum.
Buna karşı genelde insanların tepkisi
“Ya senin neren Japon?” oluyor.
Mesela kollar, bacaklar kıllı.
Göbek desen maşallah.
Sakal desen sabahında kessen
akşamında çıkıyor.
Diyorlar “Senin Japon olma ihtimalin yok.
Anne mi Japon, baban mı Japon?”
Ben de diyorum
“Annem Konyalı, babamsa Niğdeli.”
O da diyor “Ne alaka o zaman?”
İyice kafaları karışıyor,
anlamış gibi yapıp geçiyorlar.
Aslında şöyle ki ben doğma büyüme Japonum.
Japonya’da, Tokyo’da doğdum.
On beş yıl boyunca da
Japonların içinde büyüdüm.
Orada selamlaşırken böyle eğilerek
selam veriyoruz,
“konnichiwa,” “sayounara” diyerek.
Çubuklarla her zaman olmasa da
yemek yiyoruz.
Pilavlarımız yağsız tuzsuz yeniyor.
Sabahında ise pişmiş balık,
akşamında ise çiğ balık yiyoruz.
Böyle bir ortamda
on beş yıl geçirdikten sonra,
ben ailevi nedenlerden ötürü
Türkiye’ye, Türkiye’de de
Konya’ya taşınmak zorunda kaldım.
Yani Tokyo’da 15 yıl,
15′inci yılında
Tokyo’dan Konya’ya taşındım
ve bu da benim hayatımdaki
ilk büyük adımlardan biri olmuştu.
Yani tamamen bilmediğim bir yere --
yazları geliyorduk
ama çok da hani hafızam falan yoktu.
On beş yıl sonra ilk adımımı atmıştım.
Şimdi genelde bunların yarısı çok sevdiğim
Konyalı arkadaşlar olmakla birlikte,
bunu söylediğim zaman insanların tepkisi
“Aaa kanka geçmiş olsun ya” diyorlar
ya da mesela “Oğlum ne işin var,
dönsene Tokyo’ya” falan diyorlar
ama özellikle o zamanlar
ben bunu hiç anlayamıyordum.
Çünkü Konya benim, beni daha doğrusu,
bin bir türlü yenilikleriyle
ağırlayan bir şehir olmuştu.
Ben ilk defa el ele --
tabii Japonya’da da ara sıra yapıyorduk
ama böyle iki arkadaşın şak diye elinden
o sesi çıkarıp kafayla tokalaştığını
ve öyle selamlaştığını
ilk defa Konya’da gördüm.
Bu benim için yepyeni bir şeydi.
Bizde ya da mesela “muck muck” diye
sağ-sol-sağ öpüşerek selamlaşmayı
ben ilk defa Türkiye’de gördüm.
Bizde selamlaşma çeşitleri de
30, 60, 90 derece olmak üzere
eğilmenin çeşitleri var.
Ya da böyle mesela,
pilavın yağsız tuzsuz değil de
ne kadar tereyağı, o kadar güzel olduğunu
ben Konya’da gördüm gibi gibi,
hatta söylememe bile gerek yok
ama etli ekmeğin güzelliğini
ben Japonya’da hiçbir zaman tatmamıştım.
Konya’ya geldiğimde öğrendim.
Yani insanların benim kafama
yerleştirdiği o tipik algıyı kırmama,
bu adımı atmam vesile olmuştu.
Yani ben Japonya’dayken
hiçbir zaman Konya hakkında
iyi bir şey duymamıştım.
Ama geldiğimde her türlü güzelliğiyle
beni ağırlayan bir yer olduğunu
ve şu anda da net bir şekilde
ilk üç sevdiğim dünyadaki şehir
olduğunu söylemek isterim.
Bu arada belirtmeyi unuttum ama YouTube’da
yaptığım içerikler genelde gezi üzerine.
O yüzden bayağı bir ülkede
bugüne kadar bulunmuşluğum var
ve ona rağmen Konya Top 3′te şimdilik.
Bunun dışında ikinci attığım
büyük adımlarından bir tanesi
Hindistan’a gitmek olmuştur benim.
Bir gün böyle işte konforluktan
ve monoton hayattan sıkılmıştım
ve bu bana yavaş yavaş batmaya başlamıştı.
Ben o alanın dışına çıkmak istiyordum.
Konforsuzluğun dışına, bilinmezliğe doğru
bir adım atmak istiyordum
ve onun için de
attığım adımlardan bazıları şöyle:
Mesela tercümanlık yaptım,
hayatımda ilk defa tercümanlık yaptım
ve o büyük adımla birlikte gelen
maddiyat ile birlikte --
bir de tabii derslerimi iyi tutuyordum,
işte babaya diyordum “Baba bak yüz aldım.
Hani sana zahmet bir şeyler istiyorum.”
Ondan sonra, mesela, garsonluk yaptım;
hayatımda hiç yapmadığım bir şeydi.
Yani bunca farklı alanlarda ilk adımı atıp
onlardan gelen maddiyat ile birlikte
Hindistan’a biletimi almıştım
ve onunla birlikte Hindistan’a gittim.
Bu arada dipnot:
Hindistan’ı Google’da arattırdığınızda
Tac Mahal çıkıyor, lüks mimariler çıkıyor.
Ondan sonra eşsiz manzaralar çıkıyor.
Ama vardığımda beni karşılayan şey kaos.
Tamamen kaosun kendisiydi,
ilk havaalanından dışarı adımımı attım --
belki biliyorsunuzdur,
belki bilmiyorsunuzdur,
Hindistan’da bir gün bulunduğunuzda
20 paket sigara içmiş kadar
hava kirliliği oluyor.
Ben öyle manzaralar beklerken
bunun içine daldım.
Sağdan işte üstüme drift atan taksiciler.
O diyor “benim arabama binecek”
o diyor “benim arabama binecek”
O ona yumruk atıyor falan.
Önümde kavga etmeye başladılar.
Böyle kaotik bir yere gelmiştim.
Dedim “Ben ne yaptım?”
Niye işte,
ne gerek vardı konfor alanımdan çıkmaya?
Ne gerek vardı
bu konforsuzluğa adım atmaya?
“Hay dedim Hamza”
Sonra adımımı attım işte
ve Türkiye’de olsa delirirdim
dediğim ortamda
bir gün, iki gün, üç gün derken
bir hafta geçti.
Ben artık farelerle yatıp kalkıyorum.
İşte zehirlenmişim,
ikinci kez mi ne midem bulanıyor falan.
Öyle değişik günler geçirirken
bir gece Hindistan’da sokakta yürüyorum.
İşte bir tane sokak sanatçısı var.
Oturmuş arkada gitar çalıyor.
Biz de işte yirmi-otuz kişi,
oradan geçenler onu izliyoruz.
Sonra bir kız geldi,
elini kolunu savura savura geliyor falan,
dans etmeye başladı
ve o orada gülüyordu.
O kız güldükçe
ve etrafa baktığımda şunu fark ettim ki
herkesi güldürüyor bu kız,
küçücük bir Hintli kız çocuğu.
Taş çatlasın dört-beş yaşında.
Ondan sonra dans etti, yoruldu,
kaldırım kenarına geçti,
oturdu, yerden bir tane gazete aldı,
gazeteyi yırttı , gazeteyi sardı,
gazeteyi ağzına götürdü
ve dişiyle gazeteyi çiğnedi, kopardı.
Daha sonra çiğnedi, çiğnedi, çiğnedi.
O gazeteyi yuttu.
Derken ikinci yarısı.
Derken bir daha kopardı,
ağzına götürdü, yuttu.
Üçüncü, dördüncü derken o koca gazeteyi
bu Hint çocuğu bitirmişti
ve işte benim hayatımı değiştiren
ve bu adımıma anlam katan
Hint kız çocuğu.
Hayatımın aynı zamanda
dönüm noktalarından bir tanesi.
Bunu gördükten sonra
hemen bir bakkala gittim.
Hatta şöyle serçe parmağım kadar
büyüklükte bir dondurma,
ufak bir şey alayım da vereyim dedim kıza.
Verdim, kız hemen sevindi etti,
sonra “Aaa” falan filan aldı.
Ağzına götürdü dondurmayı.
Yer yemez tükürdü.
Neden? Çünkü dişleri çürük.
Zaten ondan sonra dikkatli yaklaştığımda,
gördüğümde her tarafı kaşınıyordu.
Saçları bitlenmiş bayağı.
Hani annesi, babası olduğunu
sanmadığım bir kız çocuğu,
o dondurmayı tükürdükten sonra
kumlu bir şekilde yerden tekrar aldı
ve ağzına götürdü ve mutlu mutlu yedi.
Ben Hindistan’a gittiğimde
şunu fark ettim:
Hani mesela Tokyo da büyümüşüm,
işte Konya da, İstanbul’da
vakit geçirmişim falan.
Ne kadar şanslı olduğumu, mesela,
ben bu adımı atmasam
ben bu bilinmezliğe doğru gitmeseydim
asla bilemeyecektim
böyle hayat tarzlarının olduğunu.
O gün o kızı gördüğüm zaman fark etmiştim
ve kendi hayatımda
ne kadar şanslı olduğumu öğrenmiştim.
Onun gibi bin bir türlü örnek verilir.
Mesela Afrika’ya gittim.
Afrika’da, mesela, hepsi
böyle negatif değil aslında.
Afrika’ya gittiğimde, mesela,
ben kuraklık bekliyordum.
İşte aç susuz insanlar bekliyordum.
Bir baktım Maldivler gibi
böyle doğa harikası olan bir ülke.
Bir ön yargım daha kırılmıştı.
Ondan sonra Kore'ye gittim.
Ben Kore’nin böyle işte Uzak Doğu,
Japonya gibi bir yer olmasını beklerken
insanlar bana “Merhaba” diye
direkt Türkçe konuşmaya başlamıştı.
İşte selam veriyorlar falan filan.
Koreliler hakkındaki ön yargım --
Japonlar gibi sanarken
çok daha Türk çıktı onlar.
İşte böyle bir ön yargım kırılmıştı .
Ondan sonra Avrupa'ya gittim.
Yine bir ön yargım kırıldı.
Mısır'a gittim.
Ben piramitleri beklerken, mesela,
yedi kere tutuklandım
saçma sapan nedenlerden dolayı.
Anlat anlat bitmez şimdi
ama yine mesela orada da
başka bir anlamda ön yargım kırılmıştı .
Ama iyi ya da kötü,
her ben adımımı atma cesareti bulduğumda
konforluktan konforsuzluğa doğru
geçtiğimde şunu fark ettim:
Hayatın gerçekleriyle
iyisiyle kötüsüyle yüzleşiyorum
ve yüzleştiğim zaman hiçbir şekilde
bunun bana geri dönüşü kötü olmadı.
Yani en azından gerçeği görüyorum,
öğreniyorum ve biliyorum.
Şunu söylemek istiyorum.
Lafı uzattım.
Kısacası, konfordan çıkmaktan korkmayın.
Konforsuzluğa adım atmaktan korkmayın.
Ben hala belki bir hafta sonu
bir yere gideceğim.
Korkuyorum, biletimi almadım bile yani.
Yani 2-3 yıl olmuş hala korkuyorum.
Ama inanın o adımı atıp da --
7 kere tutuklansam da, zehirlensem de,
daha 2 hafta önce Nepal’de dağda,
Everest yolunda yürüyordum
ve zehirlendim çok kötü bir şekilde,
pırpır uçakla
şehre geri dönmek zorunda kaldım.
Hatta Türkiye’ye hemen
tedavi görmeye gelmek zorunda kalmıştım.
Ama bu bile bana öyle deneyimler kattı ki
iyi ki dedim.
Bugüne kadar o adımı atıp da
keşke yapmasaydım dediğim
hiçbir zaman olmadı.
Bu hayatınızın her alanında olabilir.
Sallıyorum, lüks bir villada,
3 katlı bir villada doğmuşsunuzdur.
Hizmetçiniz size kahvenizi getiriyordur.
Gidin Starbucks’ta kahve alın.
Bu bile aslında konfora
illa böyle ekstrem bir şey değil de --
konfor alanından çıkmak
veya işte illa bir ülkeye değil de
farklı bir şehre gidin,
farklı bir semte gidin,
farklı insanlarla tanışın.
Hani yapmadığınız bir şeyi yapın.
Çünkü inanın orada sizi hiç hayal bile
edemeyeceğiniz bir kapı bekliyor.
O kapıya gidin, o adımı atarak açın
ve sizi neyin beklediğini görün.
Ben bir gezgin olarak
şunu söyleyebilirim sadece:
Hayat gerçekten keşfetmeye değer.
Sadece yapmanız gereken o ilk adımı atmak.
İyisiyle kötüsüyle bu hayatı
keşfetmenizi temenni ederim.
Sağ olun, teşekkür ederim.